aquí tenemos una gráfica en tres
dimensiones lo que significa que
representa algún tipo de función que
tiene una entrada en dos dimensiones y
una salida en una dimensión así que
podríamos ver esto y digamos que esto es
una función f de xy que es igual a bueno
pues alguna expresión verdad que tendrá
un montón de xy es en ella y bueno en
esencia las gráficas son geniales pero
digamos son un poco difíciles de dibujar
y digo ciertamente no podríamos
simplemente esbozar la aquí verdad
típicamente requiere algún tipo de
software que pueda graficar lo y cuando
tomamos una imagen estática de ella pues
no siempre es claro qué es lo que está
ocurriendo así que lo que voy a
describir aquí es digamos una forma de
representar estas funciones y estas
estas gráficas digamos de forma
bidimensional y esto es simplemente
digamos esbozando todo en un pedazo de
papel en dos dimensiones digamos así que
hay una forma común en la que veremos
esto es graficando las curvas o los
conjuntos de nivel y la idea detrás de
los conjuntos de niveles que vamos a
tomar esta gráfica y vamos a rebanar la
un montón de veces verdad así que vamos
a rebanar la con varios planos y todos
estos planos serán paralelos al plano xy
así que pensemos por un momento qué es
lo que estos tipos representan digamos
este de aquí abajo representa el valor
set igual a menos 2 y lo que estamos
haciendo es fijar el valor de z en menos
2 y dejamos a x y digamos correr
libremente en todo este plano
así que si vamos aumentando z y lo
mantenemos constante
ok digamos lo aumentamos a menos 1
entonces obtenemos un nuevo plano que
aún es paralelo al plano x pero esta
distancia de este plano en -1 verdad y
el resto de los demás verdad van a
seguir siendo valores constantes de z
ahora en términos de nuestra gráfica lo
que significa es que estos representan
valores constantes para la gráfica y por
lo tanto digamos tenemos
representaciones de las salidas de la
función verdad con justamente como la
altura que estamos digamos separándonos
del plano
y esto representa los valores constantes
que tenemos de salida y esto es como se
va a ver así que vamos a hacer esto
digamos podríamos preguntarnos dónde es
que estas rebanadas cortan a esta
gráfica verdad y vamos a dibujar todos
esos puntos en donde estas rebanadas
cortan a la gráfica verdad y es
justamente estos conjuntos de puntos a
los que llamamos líneas o curvas de
nivel y aún estamos en tres dimensiones
así que todavía no hemos terminado
verdad lo que vamos a hacer ahora es que
todas estas curvas de nivel vamos a
apachurrar las justo al plano xy así que
lo que esto significa es que cada una de
estas curvas digamos tiene cierta
componente zeta en este momento pero
vamos a bajarlos hasta que quede todo
plano y muy lindo en el plano x y ahora
tenemos un arreglo bidimensional verdad
que aún representa digamos las salidas
de nuestra función ahora bien no todo
aquí es perfecto verdad pero al menos
nos da una gran idea de qué es lo que
está ocurriendo con
nuestra función y ahora vamos a cambiar
hacia una gráfica bidimensional aquí y
esta es exactamente la misma función que
estábamos mirando antes solo que ahora
cada una de estas líneas representan un
valor constante de salida de nuestra
función así que es importante darnos
cuenta que aún representa la función
pero que tiene una entrada bidimensional
y una salida de una dimensión y
simplemente estamos fijándonos en el
espacio de entrada es verdad de nuestra
función así que esto aún es efe de
verdad que tendrá alguna expresión para
estos estas dos variables pero a lo
mejor esta línea podría representar el
valor constante de f cuando se alcanza
el valor de 3 verdad y aquí por ejemplo
también podríamos ver estos círculos que
nos dan todos los valores en donde f
tiene como salida a 3 verdad y este es
digamos este es uno por aquí que nos va
a decir cuando las salidas valen 2 y en
realidad no podemos decir simplemente de
ver digamos todas las curvas de nivel
cuáles son sus valores verdad así que
típicamente
si alguien lo está dibujando entonces
debe especificar qué valores son y lo va
a marcar de alguna forma así que de esta
forma nos va a decir qué valor a qué
valor corresponde cada curva de nivel
pero por ejemplo una vez que ya sabemos
que a esta curva corresponde al valor de
0 entonces nos dice que cualquier
posible entrada que se encuentre sobre
esta línea va a valer 0 cuando la
evaluamos en la función verdad y
entonces esto de hecho nos da una muy
buena intuición y una muy buena idea de
cómo es que esta gráfica da nuestra
función verdad si digamos si nos gusta
pensar en términos de gráficas podríamos
imaginarnos cómo es que estos círculos y
todo esto puede digamos salirse de la
página o de la pantalla verdad entonces
de hecho también podríamos fijarnos en
cómo es que estas líneas se empiezan a
juntar verdad unas con otras se empiezan
a juntar muchísimo pero por ejemplo a lo
mejor hay más espacio por aquí como
podríamos por ejemplo interpretar eso
bueno por ejemplo de este lado significa
que tenemos un paso muy muy muy pequeño
para incremento
los valores de la función digamos por un
valor 1 verdad necesitamos un paso muy
pequeño y esto incrementa digamos una
unidad simplemente dando pasos muy
pequeños pero por ejemplo de este otro
lado necesitamos un paso más grande para
incrementar la función por el mismo
valor así que tenemos distintas formas
de medir digamos que tan inclinada o qué
tan pronunciada es nuestra gráfica y
veremos a la gráfica como un todo verdad
y la idea digamos de cuando tenemos
muchos círculos concéntricos usualmente
corresponde a cuando tenemos un máximo o
un mínimo de nuestra función verdad y
vamos a encontrar mucho este este patrón
en más ejemplos verdad otra cosa común
que la gente hace con digamos con las
curvas de nivel es que las representa
con colores así que digamos esto podría
verse más o menos así aquí digamos los
colores más cálidos como el naranja
corresponden a valores más altos y los
colores más digamos frigios como el azul
corresponden a valores más bajos así que
las líneas de nivel o las curvas de
nivel terminan dictando
una división entre digamos por ejemplo
el rojo y el verde aquí entre el verde
claro y el verde y también tenemos una
forma digamos en que los colores nos
dicen algo sobre las salidas de nuestra
función verdad y las y las curvas de
nivel mismas pueden pensarse como los
bordes entre distintos colores así que
otra vez tenemos una muy buena forma de
obtener más intuición de cómo es una
función multidimensional simplemente
fijándonos en el espacio de entradas